How
to reshape the object that was today
It's
alchemy Alchemist brothers Ed and Al fail trying to revive Morira's mother
Ed is Yasuyo or lost all of his body
It
's called your warehouse
I'll do anything for me It's so funny that
I don't have it if I'm doing something like this If you're dealing with a fare span, please say something like this
I
[music] Don't
let me regain the body that lost the gold fight  What is absolutely necessary for the
philosopher's stone is just the previous section. The philosopher's stone is good.
That brother is helping me and this color is not caught.
Our plan is a dynas person. The text
can't be put to good use anymore. The
remaining
ni
Ah ah ah Then
I was proud while thinking about this
[Music]
Fullmetal Alchemist